SO WHAT PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
WILL TELL HIM WILL SURPRISE YOU.
FIRST, THE GREAT TRUMP RECOVERY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
ONLY A FEW MORE SHOWS BEFORE
TUESDAY.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL ONE ON SUNDAY
COMING UP.
I WANT YOU TO HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION YOU NEED GOOD WON’T
HEAR ANYWHERE ELSE BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
FIRST, AS THE BIDEN BOOSTERS
BROUGHT YOU FREAKING OUT ABOUT
COVID CASE NUMBERS, WE SHOULD
INSTEAD BE CELEBRATING TONIGHT.
AMERICA’S GDP NUMBER THAT WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED WERT NOT FOR
THE SMART DECISIONS MADE BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TODAY’S THIRD-QUARTER GDP
REPORTS OF UP WHAT IS ASTOUNDING
ASTOUNDING.
33.1% ON ANNUALIZED BASIS AND
REMEMBER IT WASN’T SO LONG AGO
THAT THE EXPERTS HAD A DIFFERENT
GDP IN MIND.
GREAT DEPRESSION POSSIBLE.
SPEAK WITH THE RATE.
>> NUMBERS WE HAVEN’T SEEN SINCE
THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
>> HAVE WE GONE PAST THE R WORD,
RECESSION, TO THE D WORD?
>> >> Laura: [LAUGHS]
THE D WORD.
ARE THEY HAVE A RIGHT?
NO AND THEY NEVER ADMIT THEY
WERE WRONG.
THEY DO THEIR BEST TO DOWNPLAY
ANY GOOD NEWS.
>> THAT NUMBER, IT’S GANGBUSTERS
BUT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER IT’S
AFTER A RECORD CRASH.
>> DON’T EXPECT THAT GROWTH TO
LAST AT THAT PACE.
>> WE GOT NEW GOTTEN ONE
APPOINTMENT NUMBERS.
>> THE NUMBERS TRENDING DOWN,
GOOD NEWS BUT IT’S STILL
NEGATIVELY HIGH.
>> THIS WAS THE EASY PART AND TO
CHRISTINE’S POINT, THERE ARE
SOME REAL OBSTACLES LYING AHEAD.
>> Laura: THAT WAS THE EASY
PART, THEY WERE SAYING.
WHAT TRUMP DID WAS THE EASY
PART, REALLY?
THEN WHY DIDN’T EUROPE REPLICATE
THIS LEVEL OF GDP GROWTH?
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S STEWARDSHIP OF
OUR ECONOMY WAS SO OBVIOUS, WHY
IS IT THAT EVERY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE G7 IS DOING MUCH
WORSE.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SURVEY
OF ECONOMISTS HAS IS ONLY DOWN
3.6% FOR THE YEAR, MARKEDLY
BETTER THAN WHAT THE IMS
ESTIMATES THAT EVERY ONE OF OUR
EUROPEAN COUNTERPARTS.
DO NOT FORGET THIS CHARGE.
LOOK AT IT.
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE.
LOOK AT WHERE ITALY IS.
LOOK AT WHERE EVEN GERMANY AS
COMPARED TO US.
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO SEE THAT
CHARGE ANYWHERE ELSE ON
TELEVISION.
REMEMBER THESE COUNTRIES ALL
STAYED IN LOCKDOWN LONGER THAN
WE DID AND THEY ALL DO CONTACT
TRACKING AND TRACING.
THEY’LL HAVE MASS MANDATES.
THEY BLEW UP THEIR ECONOMIES
WITH THESE LONG WALK COUNTS, AND
YET THEIR CASES STILL EXPLODED.
AND NOW MOST OF THEM ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF LOCKING DOWN AGAIN.
COMPLETE LUNACY.
LORD KNOWS HOW BAD OUR
THIRD-QUARTER GDP NUMBER
WOULD’VE BEEN IF WE HAD STAYED
LOCKED DOWN ALL THROUGH THE
SUMMER, LIKE BIDEN’S EXPERTS
PREFERRED THAT IN NOW.
>> I THINK THAT IN PERSON
SCHOOLING, ARE LIKELY GOING TO
-- WERE GOING TO HAVE TO
RECONSIDER THOSE PARTICULAR
PARTS OF SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
YES, CERTAIN PARTS OF SOCIETY
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OPEN WILL
LIKELY HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AS THIS OUTBREAK
CONTINUES TO WORSEN.
I DO THINK WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO RECONSIDER STRATEGIC
LOCKDOWNS.
>> Laura: ANYONE ELSE BUT I?
IN OTHER WORDS, UNDER A
PRESIDENT BIDEN, PREPARE FOR THE
ECONOMIC CALAMITY THAT IS
HAPPENING IN EUROPE.
YOU CAN RUN BUT YOU CANNOT HIDE
FROM A VIRUS.
THE PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS THAT A
FREE NATION OF OUR SIZE CANNOT
PLAY WITH PEOPLE’S LIVELIHOOD
LIKE THIS.
>> WE ARE NEVER GOING TO LOCK
DOWN AGAIN.
WE UNDERSTOOD THE DISEASE, AND
NOW WE ARE OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
JOE BIDEN’S PLAN IS TO DELIVER
PUNISHING LOCKDOWNS.
THERE WILL BE NO SCHOOLS.
NO GRADUATIONS, NO WEDDINGS, NO
THANKSGIVING.
NO CHRISTMAS, NO FOURTH OF JULY.
THERE WILL BE NOTHING.
>> Laura: THE LEFT HERE AND
ABROAD IS USING THE TRAGEDY OF
THIS PANDEMIC TO TURN OVER
POLITICAL DECISION-MAKING TO
UNELECTED HEALTH EXPERTS WHO
HAVE ZERO ACCOUNTABILITY TO YOU.
REGARDLESS OF HOW WRONG THEY
HAVE BEEN IN MODEL AFTER MODEL,
THEY WANT US TO HAVE NO CHOICE
IN THE MATTER WHENEVER THEY
DECIDE TO PUT THE BRAKES ON
FREEDOM.
SO IF YOUR KIDS ASK YOU WHY
TUESDAY MATTERS, WELL, TELL
THEM.
BECAUSE OUR FREEDOM MATTERS.
BECAUSE WITHOUT FREEDOM, WHAT
ARE WE ANYWAY?
MILLIONS OF TARIFFS WAITING TO
RECEIVE NEW RULES FROM NAMELESS
FACELESS BUREAUCRATS?
ALWAYS WORRIED THAT YOU’RE GOING
TO BE RATTED OUT BY THE
GOVERNMENT APPARATCHIKS
MONITORING HOW MANY CARS ARE
PARKED IN YOUR DRIVEWAY?
THAT’S NOT AMERICA.
THAT’S THE SOVIET UNION CIRCA
1977.
I’LL NEVER FORGET REAL 3M ON
ELECTION NIGHT STANDING 20 FEET
FROM THE STAGE WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP DELIVER THESE
WORDS.
>> I’VE GOTTEN TO KNOW OUR
COUNTRY SO WELL.
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
IT’S GOING TO BE A BEAUTIFUL
THING.
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALIZE HIS
OR HER FULLEST POTENTIAL.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
OUR COUNTRY WILL BE FORGOTTEN NO
LONGER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: FORGOTTEN NOT MORE.
HE MEANT IT.
ALONG WITH TAX CUTS AND
DEREGULATION.
HE CRACKED DOWN ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND TOOK ON THE
TRADE ABUSES OF CHINA.
NOW THAT PART WAS RESISTED BY
BIG BUSINESS WHICH IS ADDICTED
TO CHEAP LABOR, WHILE
PRESIDENT TRUMP KEPT HIS FOCUS
ON THE AMERICAN WORKER.
LOOK AT BIDEN.
OLD JOE HAS BEEN BUCKLING UNDER
PRESSURE TO BIG MONEY INTERESTS
FOR SO LONG HE PROBABLY DOESN’T
EVEN REMEMBER HIS FIRST
PRINCIPLE.
NOW HE JUST DOES WHAT HE’S TOLD.
IN 1973 HE PROBABLY DIDN’T EVER
THINK HE WOULD SELL AT THE
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS IN SCRANTON
AFTER BEING PRESSURED BY THE
OUTSOURCERS.
I’M SURE THE SAME INDUSTRY
THOUGHT THEY COULD GET
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SELL OUT TOO.
>> SOMEBODY WENT TO WALL STREET.
YOU’RE THE ONE THAT TAKES ON THE
MONEY FROM WALL STREET.
I DON’T TAKE IT.
YOU HAVE RAISED A LOT OF MONEY.
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF MONEY.
EVERY TIME YOU RAISE MONEY,
DEALS ARE MADE.
I COULD CALL THE HEADS OF
WALL STREET, THE HEADS OF EVERY
COMPANY IN AMERICA.
BUT I DON’T WANT TO DO THAT
BECAUSE IT PUTS ME IN A BAD
POSITION.
>> Laura: -- IT PUTS ME IN A
BAD POSITION.
WALL STREET IS NOT POURING MONEY
INTO THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
HE’S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO
INFLUENCE.
THEY ARE PUTTING MONEY INTO
BIDEN CAMPAIGN BECAUSE THEY KNOW
HE’S AN EASY MARK.
THIS IS SOMETHING YOU NEED TO
KEEP IN MIND FOR TUESDAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ENORMOUS
COURAGE.
MOST MEN WOULD’VE SOLD OUT LONG
AGO JUST TO MAKE THINGS EASIER
ON THEMSELVES.
BUT HE DIDN’T.
OUR REGULAR WORKING CLASS HEROES
KNOW IT.
EVEN DEMOCRATIC DEBBIE DINGELL
HAD TO CONCEDE.
>> SOMEBODY AUTOWORKERS.
THEY WERE CLEAR WITH ME THEY
WERE VOTING FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
AUTOWORKERS SENT?
HE SAID I’M TIRED OF YOUR
DEMOCRATIC FRIENDS.
THEY LOOKED DOWN ON ME.
>> Laura: THEY DO LOOK DOWN ON
YOU.
OF COURSE THOSE WORKERS CAN’T
WRITE BIG CAMPAIGN CHECKS.
THE PRESIDENT DID THE RIGHT
THING, INCREASING MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME BY MORE THAN
$6,000.
AMAZING.
WHICH BRINGS US ALL BACK TO
JOE’S RUNNING MATE, COVID.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HAVING SEEN
WHAT A MEDIA SUPERSTAR DR. FAUCI
HAD BECOME, HE COULDN’T JUST LET
FAUCI DECIDE EVERYTHING.
FROM WHEN IT IS SAFE TO GET ON A
TRAIN TO WHEN YOUR KIDS CAN PLAY
T-BALL AGAIN.
THE MEDIA WOULD’VE LOVED THAT,
ALL THOSE DAILY COVID BRIEFINGS,
ALL THE TALK OF SHARED
SACRIFICE.
AS THEY HEADED OFF TO THE
HAMPTONS TO BLOW OFF STEAM ON
THE WEEKENDS.
THANK GOD TRUMP KNEW THAT
LISTENING TO JUST ONE TYPE OF
EXPERT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE
AND YES, DANGEROUS.
IN FLORIDA TODAY, BIDEN CLAIMS
THAT THE PRESIDENT ENDANGER THE
COUNTRY FIND NOT LISTENING TO
THE EXPERTS.
NO, JOE.
TRUMP LIKELY SAVED US BY
RESISTING THEIR UNPROVEN
STRATEGIES THAT SOMEHOW SOMEWAY
ALWAYS LEAD TO MORE POWER FOR